allora in questi diciotto minuti
più o meno quello che farò vera contro
di alcune cose che forse avete già
sentito parlare in parte in modo più o
meno approfondito per il resto invece
valore attività che non potete conoscere
perché sono delle cose che degli
esperimenti che portano avanti i miei
giovani collaboratori giova teramo
quello che vedete in questa diapositiva
alle mie spalle e l'aula cuore insomma
la uai page di una delle associazioni
che vi chiamate agli ucn l'iucn è un
composto ovviamente no profit da
qualcosa come 40 mila scienziati quindi
biologi eccetera persone appassionati di
questo pianeta che vanno in giro per il
pianeta e quello che fanno monitorio non
tengono sotto controllo tutto lo stato
di salute del pianeta
ovviamente mandando a contare censendo
le specie vegetali e le specie animali
dopo di che stilano un rapporto appunto
annuale red list ma che fa la vostra
dove vedono gli animali o le piante che
se la passano bene quindi perfetto stato
di salute gli animali invece il cui
numero sta riducendo leggermente
minacciata oppure gravemente minacciata
di estinzione ovviamente oppure estinte
in natura ma viventi bioparchi 8 oppure
persa estinta per sempre estinta per
sempre vuol dire che quell'animale non
sarà più con noi il problema
estremamente serio si parla poco farle
ne parlava nella the thing che abbiamo
visto il collega americano parlava di
cinque estinzioni sul pianeta in effetti
questa è la quinta estinzione di massa
del pianeta
ora mentre sulle precedenti a parte in
quella causa quella degli di rosari come
sapete causata dall'impatto della terra
con asteroide non abbiamo veramente
conosciamo i motivi delle estinzioni in
corso se abbiamo esattamente che
responsabile noi e sappiamo esattamente
le specie che stanno scomparendo
l'ultimo censimento parla di cinque
oltre 5 mila specie ed essendo
veterinario quello che mi preoccupa in
modo particolare sono i mammiferi ce ne
sono 100 80 di questi
scomparendo 130 di questi sono grossi
mammiferi nuovamente rendete conto che
istituì da soli parlano e dicono
chiaramente il problema di grande
serietà tant'è vero che come sapete non
so se lo sapete pratica del suino le
nazioni unite hanno hanno indetto il
decennio 2011 2020 decennio della
biodiversità
cosa vogliono fare con questo vogliono
un po stimolare chi prende decisioni
ecco porre più attenzione al problema e
se possibile a trasformare questo in
degli interventi mirati l'altra cosa che
senz'altro vi sorprenderà buona parte di
voi
quando parliamo di distinzione
immediatamente delle icone tipo panda
piuttosto che la tigre o rinoceronte
albino insomma che in vengono le nostre
anello nella nostra mente
in effetti non è così stanno scomparendo
un numero enorme o 20 per cento circa di
razze domestiche
quindi vorrei dirvi polli conigli cani
cavalli bovini suini stanno
progressivamente scomparendo nel senso
che vengono rimpiazzati
scalzati sostituiti da delle specie
animali più produttive vengono chiamate
cosiddetti industriali dai tecnici
questo vuol dire che tanti di queste
popolazioni adattati alle condizioni
climatiche ambientali modo spesso sono
l'origine i prodotti di nicchia e quindi
anche gli aspetti culturali vanno via
saranno via quello voi vedete io sono
nato in sardegna quindi mi sono occupato
indovinate di che cosa di pecore tu
nasci in sardegna essi pecore non potevo
fare altro e su queste rimarrà ho
lavorato e sulla sua variante ovviamente
saltati anche buffon e quello che vedete
alle mie spalle sono le immagini delle
razze
dei progenitori diciamo così delle razze
ovine domestiche che sono allevate
intorno a mediterraneo
ora tutti questi animali ovviamente
stanno scomparendo quindi questo è un
patrimonio genetico e culturale secondo
me enorme per cui la prima cosa da fare
secondo me per lasciare questi animali
indisturbati non non ridurre gli areali
anzi plea ficali questa la strategia
migliore
ci sono però degli particolari casi in
cui bisogna intervenire quando quando le
popolazioni animali scendono oltre un
certo numero per esempio una popolazione
di bovini selvatici composta da sette
femmine e tre maschi inevitabilmente va
incontra distinzione inevitabilmente si
innesca una spesa annua spirare in
negativo per cui riduce la fertilità
aumenta la mortalità embrionale
dell'animale se ne va in quel caso è
possibile che un tecnico come me che
sciupa di embrioni dei chirurgi
embrionali possa dare il suo contributo
come boe senz'altro vin tutti i
familiari il concetto della d'olivi
ricordate la pecora clonata
essenzialmente si prendono cita una
cellula uovo si svuotano i propri
cromosomi che vengono sostituiti da
questa cellula differenziato nasceva
dalla pelle per esempio e io quindi
faccio questo copia incolla copia
incolla e o da dieci animali mille
diecimila quindi spostando il rischio
dalle istituzioni questi animali la cosa
interessante che questa tecnologia della
colazione sono riguarda prima missili
hanno curato tutte le specie domestiche
anche gli animali da compagnia
ma si possono curare degli insetti di
fede i pesci delle rane questo hanno
sempre fatto per cui la tecnologia
trasversale estremamente interessante
che possiamo applicare a tutte le specie
animali
il problema come si va anzitutto giusto
due cenni tecnici sono interventi di
microchirurgia ovviamente non voglio
tediarvi con questo giusto quello che
vedete è una cellula uovo sono tutti
così nei mammiferi vengono immobilizzati
insomma quindi capitare diventano
dopodiché si tolgono i cromosomi sono
questi che vedete questi punti di blu e
dopodiché viene fecondata questa cellula
uovo da una cellula somatica inizia lo
sviluppo embrionale abbiamo un animale
il problema qual è il problema che non
funziona ancora bene una tecnologia
assolutamente sperimentale non
conosciamo quello che facciamo
l'efficienza e bassissima dovete
produrre 100 animali per cento embrioni
di scusate per avere un animale per cui
stiamo lavorando affinché questa tecnica
diventa affidabile risk free come si
dice oggi nel frattempo però quello che
bisogna fare è che bisogna iniziare come
dei autorevoli scienziati stanno facendo
per il lecce tradate
l'accogliente delle linee cellulari di
questi animali prima che sia troppo
tardi
questo è quello che si sta chiedendo
sempre più insistentemente la guida
scientifica ma anche dalla gente comune
ed effetti chiunque si occupi di queste
cose sa la sua banchina anche durban da
riva in laboratorio un animale
particolare un camoscio appenninico per
esempio prendo se sono spermatozoi di
congelo cedole con gel e così via quindi
tutti noi piano piano
diciamo artigianalmente si chiama le
essendo queste banche pochi sugli sforzi
come quello che vedete alle mie spalle
invece più organizzati diciamo così di
conservare questo materiale
queste cellule vengono conservate come
vengono conservati tutte le cellule si
mettono medium e si tengono congelati
innanzitutto liquido l'azoto liquido a
196 gradi sotto zero
freddissimo funziona bene tecniche su
robusti e affidabili e voi congelate
scongelate 70 cellule di questi 100
metri concetto su vive
dove sono i problemi i problemi sono i
costi sono i costi perché l'azoto
liquido costa no produrlo ha un impatto
ambientale perché vengono prodotte tanto
è tornati di co2
l'altro problema è che il 70 per cento
degli animali di cui mi hai parlato
vivono in africa per liberamente tenerla
giù di liquido estremamente costoso poco
probabile allora iniziato a chiedermi si
può fare qualcosa per insomma qualche
soluzione più economica e che possa
consentirci di espandere queste banche
genetiche esiste adesso anche io vi
porto indietro di duemila anni fa circa
perché oltre alla biologia un'altra
grande passione che ultimamente emergere
quindi più che l'archeologia e io adesso
vi porto qualcosa ma due anni fa come se
ne siamo in israele
siamo sul lo sapete 76 dopo cristo gli
romani hanno distrutto con questa di
israele distrutto il tempio e hanno
assediato quale la rottura di masada una
tribù ebraica composta dai 250 individui
hanno formati campo lo vedete gli allora
fino alla sinistra
ok hanno lanciato il loro assedio e dopo
di che in effetti dopo due anni vanno
sommati tutti i libri erano con me sul
suicidio e non ho trovato nulla
questa la ragazza vedete nella
diapositiva destra è la l'archeologa che
ha partecipato agli scavi e lì ha
trovato diverse manciate libe semi di
parma la data di datteri e ha fatto
quello che avrei fatto io avremo fatto
tutti noi che prendiamo questi datteri
mettiamoli in un vasetto diamo acqua e
sorprendentemente sono nate delle armi
dopo duemila anni
questa la cosa straordinaria oltre che
il dna e straordinaria testabile
iniziato occuparmi di questa storia e mi
sono guardato intorno perché non c'è
niente secondo me noi basta studiare
bene quello che ci circonda la natura
già provveduto a tutto quanto questa un
animale che si chiama tardigrado sono
gli animali strani sono circa 1 mm di
lunghezza
piove si tratta un evidente vivono sulle
tegole e hanno questa vita loro insomma
non è granché presumo sociale non piove
va via non cp acqua vivono stato anni
dello progressivamente cedono quasi
disidratano assumono l'aspetto che
vedete è se ne stanno buoni una
settimana due settimane 100 giorni anni
piove di nuovo e iniziano questa loro
bella vita va bene qual è il segreto di
questa di male non l'ho scoperto io dei
colleghi che lavorano allo scarno
scoperto che questi animali riescono a
sopravvivere perché producono uno
zucchero chiama trealosio il quale
protegge queste cellule dal de sica
vento detto fantastico
allora facciamo così chiaro un amico
israeliano ovviamente perché ho capito
che le cose sai che durano a lungo e ho
detto lynn fili siamo cellule per poi
utilizzare queste cellule utilizzate e
fare
skopje pest copia incolla della
clonazione e lui in effetti le miglio
fili zavala le cellule con trealosio e
me le mandava per via posta a teramo
ovviamente era complicato perché tutte
le volte dovevo spiegare che non è
l'aspetto da polvere ma polvere bianca e
sembra veramente sembra della cocaina
quando poi dicevo che un era cocaina
merano scivoli utilizzate i veterinari
allora vi riteneva che fossi un totale
cretino perché attraverso questi ai
francesi smetti di fare questo perché
non porta nessuna parte ho preso queste
cellule le abbiamo invitate non lo
faccio questo lavoro l'ha fatto in
giapponese che lavorava con noi
e queste cellule dopo cinque anni tenute
secche come avete visto sono state io
uso un termine forte resuscitate dalla
lucida e hanno avviato lo sviluppo
embrionale dopo cinque anni abbiamo
ripetuto l'esperimento dopo sette o otto
anni anzi continuano e vive questa
straordinario nessuno voleva primi prima
di tutto io non potevo credere quello
che vedevo ma neanche l'editore abbiamo
messo due anni per pubblicare questo
lavoro per fortuna ne sono ripetuto
degli altri sulla somma su altri animali
maiale quant'altro la cosa è stabilita
queste come il prodotto finito anzi meno
seconda tranche una da una vayas non
potrebbe fare fuoco e con le quali
prodotto finito giuro cielo gli
utilizzato in un altro
allora ovviamente noi andiamo ancora
avanti perché insomma io voglio capire
come far meglio ancora il dna vegetale
di un animale sono gli stessi ovviamente
decide sulla differenza in questo modo
siamo riusciti a tenere vivo il nucleo
no però la cellula no e allora come i
campioni della longevità sono i semi
andando a fondo scoperto che hanno fatto
germinare semi di una pianta schiavo
lupino dopo 35 mila anni 35 mila anni
secchi e poi quello che stiamo facendo
la cosa molto semplice stiamo di
nutrendo diciamo così facciamo esprimere
queste proteine si chiamano lea
lasciamolo come la crew una crono le ha
un nome di donna che ci dà una mano a
risolvere questo problema e stiamo
utilizzando queste proteine per
migliorare le performance della
l'utilizzazione delle cellule di questo
io spero l'anno venturo tra due anni di
racconta qualcosa di più interessante se
riusciamo
questo è il lavoro che facciamo in
laboratorio sul campo ovviamente le cose
staranno a davanti in israele questa è
una gazzella gen eliana che prima le
palanche la bibbia abbondava da quelle
parti e prodotti a qualche decina di
anni di capi e quello che vedete in
basso a destra e ha migliorato il
collega veterinario che stavo si sta
occupando di questo salvataggio genetico
va in giro nel deserto questa che vedete
una razza che si chiama barbie di una
razza di pecore che è stata che vi
vinton a gerico allora intorno a gerico
l'allevamento ovino iniziati intorno a
12 mila anni fa
questa è una gestori e un progenitore di
queste razze e ovviamente presenti i
numeri ridottissimi quindi quello stiamo
facendo e cercare un po di allestire
queste banche genetiche
poi questi prodotto finito in fiale su
quella che fa mi legavano sia un pochino
b eleganti sono più carina queste 20
sono risvolti bellici che si presume su
strani come le organizzano è la cosa più
curiosa perché questi riacquistata
passata agli italiani su straordinaria
la mentalità imprenditoriale
sviluppatissima e quindi questo collega
israeliano ha preso nella bibbia adesso
ritorniamo sulla bibbia chissà perché ho
trovato tanti interventi che parlano di
questo è andato nel vecchio testamento
voi sapete contiene tutte le istruzioni
dimensionali lunghezza larghezza
scompartimenti materiale di partenza per
produrre l'arca e ha costruito un arca
nel deserto israeliano dove stanno
mettendo questi soli utilizzate
quand ero un ragazzino leggendo la
bibbia trovavo estremamente difficile
capire come noi avesse potuto incastra
laden tra elefanti coccodrilli e tutto
il resto perché era complicato viste le
dimensioni
adesso invece vedete qua ci sono
qualcosa come 250 milioni di cellule di
pecora barberi fatti 250 milioni
in questa arca di noè verso veramente io
sono confidente sul sicuro che là dentro
ci possono stare tutti gli animali in
via di estinzione non di questo pianeta